all right the Cleveland Browns are two
and five and one of the big moves they
made in the offseason obviously was a
trade for Odell Beckham jr. ohto Beckham
Junior is not having a great season and
he's also not winning and I you know
it's one thing for a receiver to
complain about not getting the ball when
the team is winning you come off as a
selfish ass Ryan right when the team is
losing and you're not getting the ball
then it's very easy to say well if I was
getting the ball maybe we'd be winning
so I'm justified to say what what I want
to say and here's what he said yesterday
after the game he was asked about
Stephon Gilmore and he prays to fajn
Gilmore and he was going against a faun
Gilmore and what Otto Beckham junior
said about the Browns approach was I
felt like we didn't challenge as much as
we could have I think we kind of shied
away from it I was expecting and looking
forward to it but that wasn't the case
today we had a couple of plays but for
whatever reason we didn't do as much
challenging as we had talked about other
than that whatever came my way pretty
much I caught whatever opportunities I
had to make the most of them you can
only control what you can control I mean
you know I guess that's the most tactful
way possible to say why didn't they
throw me the ball more and it's either a
knock on Baker Mayfield for not pulling
the trigger or it's a knock on on
Freddie kitchens or the coaching staff
for not calling the plays that were
intended to be more aggressive and to
challenge but you know I'm gonna go back
to what I always say and this is the
Patriots brilliance it's never about
getting the ball to a certain guy no
it's about throwing the ball to the open
man and if you're open you get the ball
if you're not you don't get the ball the
problem is odo Beckham junior thinks
he's open even when he's not well yeah I
mean it hasn't gotten the way he would
like I would think or the way Baker
Mayfield or Freddie kitchens liked I
mean there's been plenty of
opportunities where he has been open you
know there's been misfires he's dropped
a few you know Baker's about to throw
him throw him the ball and he gets
sacked or you know Baker doesn't see him
when he's open a handful of times this
year - there's certainly been all of
that that have kind of led to an
underwhelming year statistically for
Odell Beckham jr. yeah I'll be
interested to see when I go back and
watch that film because it did just on
TV look like that the Patriots played
man-to-man on Odell Beckham jr. more
than I've seen teams play him and I
think
where he's probably talking about going
like hey step on Gilmore's awesome but
you know it sounds like he was led to
believe if he gets one on one against
Gilmore that they were gonna let him
work and do his thing and they were just
gonna play match up football and go hey
we think our guys better than your guy
even though your guys are really good
too and of course there are a lot of
teams that do that but that Bob would
say believe that though and not do it
that may create a bigger problem giving
them a false impression that you're
going to actually attack and you don't
yeah that's a problem
edible yeah it's it's it is a problem
especially when you lose you know I just
think it's one of those things as the
week goes and they see the coverage and
I'm sure Freddie kitchens and often some
meetings and everything like that they
talk about it a lot and I don't know if
it was a Baker Mayfield thing if it was
a pass protection thing okay certainly
their turnovers led to you know their
offense not being able to quite run the
way they wanted to it stopped them from
getting dual flow with the football game
before they were way too down and then
they had to kind of change their their
formula in general but either way I
still think Odell Beckham jr. you know
tough times yes he's handling himself
the right way you can't say that there's
I don't think he's trying to stoke the
the fires here or do anything like that
I think he was just trying to give me an
honest answer he wish he would have got
a chance to attack a little bit more in
one-on-one and and that's it I don't
think he realizes the impact of his work
yeah I got just like on Wednesday when
he was praising the Patriots so
over-the-top so incessantly that if
you're Freddie kitchens the coach of the
team or Baker Mayfield the quarterback
of the team and you're thinking boy this
is not the most flattering possible
comparison between me and Bill Belichick
or me and Tom Brady and I think that if
you would apply truth serum to Odell
Beckham jr. he'd say boy I'm gonna spend
the next couple of days just staring at
my phone to see if I get a phone call
that I've been traded to the Patriots
cuz I'd love to get traded to the
Patriots no you talked to Tom Brady
after the game out in the hallway and
I'm sure Tom Brady would love to have
him sure but there's no freaking way
that's happening I know it's not happy
the Browns are too hardheaded to admit
their mistake well why but then you
think the Browns deep down if you apply
truth serum to John Dorsey do you think
he'd say I regret trading Frodo but I
don't I don't think he will well it's
still too early in the process to just
say that and and again this is a Browns
team that yeah a lot of us so early in
the process are seven games
yeah there's seven games in there
talking about the grand scheme of what
they can be I mean yeah we thought maybe
they'd get into playoffs this year we
weren't sure how things would work out
we'll see if they can go on a run but
this is more than just about this year I
mean they made this play to make sure
him and Baker Mayfield are one of the
top combos going forward for the next
few years and I still think that's a
very real possibility as they kind of
find their way I think that if it's
gonna happen it happens quickly right it
happens quickly it doesn't take time it
happens and here's part of the problem
too
when you don't show up for the off
season program remember everyone dance
Freddie kitchens what's he missing yeah
and say the offense yeah yeah right
no I listen he's not gonna win any PR
battles when things are not going good
or Baker Mayfield misses him on a few
throws and people can throw that back
into your face that hey well maybe you
would have if you were here in May maybe
you guys would have completed that pass
I get all that yes I think it's deeper
than that but you know yeah he gave he
gave the public and guys like us one
more bullet to shoot with the fact of
him not being there in the offseason
OTAs and things like that I don't think
it's that big of a deal I think it's all
the Browns figuring out how they want to
play on offense Baker Mayfield not
playing as well yes they need to be a
little bit better and finding ways to
get him the ball in the drop back pass
game but they're a work in progress and
there are a young football team here's
my take on it Oh Becca jr. he's still
young there's a certain amount of
naivete there a certain amount of
conscious and willing to Eva Tay and he
knows what he can do well he knows he's
a great receiver arguably not numbers
wise this year but overall skill set
made it best in the NFL right he is
craving badly he is aching for an
organization where everyone else is it
the same level he's at sure and he was
hoping he could kind of will the Browns
to that point he's realizing the Browns
aren't there the Patriots are the one
team where everyone else fits with what
he brings to the table sure that's why I
think he keeps talking about it he keeps
thinking about it and deep down he keeps
hoping for it I don't fault him for it
yeah I don't fault him for it at all you
know Antonio Brown got to pick
essentially where he went when he was
traded he got to veto this trade in that
trade the Giants didn't give out Oh
Beckham junior a chance to have any
input whatsoever right cuz if you're
Odell Beckham jr. and they talk to you
about trades I had trade me to the trade
me to the Patriots how will redo my
contract I'll do whatever I need to do
yeah but and and and I just I feel like
this is getting closer and close to the
point where if the Browns lose enough
games these comments are going to be
more pointed he's gonna start to get
jaded and I think if it was going to
work with Baker Mayfield it would work
already and here's the other question
too deep down is Baker Mayfield think
we'd be better off without this guy
around and then you get into an issue
with Jarvis Landry and Odell or great
friends how do we ever
how do we pull this off how do we work
this but it's it's it's dysfunctional
especially because the expectations were
so high yeah and they did a poor job of
reining them in and that goes to the
organization that goes to Freddie
kitchens and you know we could talk
about this for another 20 minutes I
think Freddie kitchens is over his skis
he's so far over his skis he doesn't
know he has skis on well I mean hey
there's been moments yeah where
everything's reared his ugly head you
know whether you know it's O'Dell okay
comments like this and yeah you know he
fumbles against the 49ers trying to make
something happen okay yeah you know
Baker fit Mayfield's thrown a number of
dumb interceptions this year Freddie
kitchens has had some coaching blunders
its fourth and 11 yeah and the punt team
goes out on the field right because he
didn't have their [ __ ] together yeah
when it was fourth down I had a time
knowing that we're gonna go for it so he
deliberately doesn't fall start yeah
because he didn't want to use the
timeout right so he put his offense back
on the field with force and fourth and
16 I mean that when have we ever seen
that where you get yourself in a bad
spot yep on a key play where you're
trying to keep yourself in the game and
instead of using that timeout you take a
penalty and make it harder to convert
the fourth down who converts fourth and
16 yes pretty against the Patriots I
know so I mean this is this is careening
out of control for the Browns
and you know here's the problem that
organization once Jimmy has them bought
the team they developed such a
reputation for firing people too early
they now feel like they have to hold
onto people too long they held onto Hugh
Jackson for too long that was a mistake
and they're gonna hold on to Freddie
kitchens for two well maybe I don't know
there so they're going in the right
direction they just you know I think the
big question we had was can they win
club could they win close football games
are they a battle-tested team can they
hand their situational football whatever
see you point to to support they're
going in the right direction because you
know what they pi yesterday in games
where i just go okay
yes they had some self-inflicted wounds
but they're talented enough to where
they're not outclassed on the field by
teams like the patriots anymore they
outplayed the seattle seahawks they were
toe-to-toe with the rams
when Baker Mayfield decided to run the
draw play on fourth and nine I mean you
know some of that stuff I don't get you
know the 49ers game it's ten nothing
they're going into the end zone there's
a walk in touchdown and Baker Mayfield
throws a rocket behind Antonio
Callaway's legs one foot off the ground
he tries to catch it it pops it in the
air so the the blame is all around
you're right and ultimately when you say
the blame is all around that goes back
to the head coach and the GM and the
owner and I get all of that we'll see
yeah that's tough stretch right let's
see if they can rebound here doesn't
you're a little easier it does soften
but here's the thing
I feel like as the talent improves these
little moments here and there that
they've yet to master that caused games
to fall apart become more glaring yeah
become more I guess usable yeah so
especially when you go Rams Ravens 49 or
Seahawks Patriots I mean that's that's
some of the best teams we have in the
league right now well they get the
Steelers twice in the back half and that
looks like easy that's not easy Steelers
are gonna want to remind everyone yeah
that the Browns are still the little
brothers right Browns are gonna be
behind the Steelers in the standings
when they play and it's still looking to
everything they can to keep them there
all right that's
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports